survey says I have a marriage proposal  that was a winner  a Fayetteville North Carolina man asked  his girlfriend a series of wedding  related questions during a game of  family feud but saved the most important  part for last take a look at this name  of day a woman always dreams of her  wedding day how would you finish this  will you marry  [Laughter]  so Josh look at her Josh when Keyon I've  been together since high school they  planned to tie the knot in 2021 after  she graduates from nursing school but  you know guys when she said yeah I will  she didn't realize that that was the  option until he got down on one knee and  just you know melted it was such a  beautiful moment some of the questions  were so name something a woman wears all  white to something old  finish the sentence something old  something new something borrowed  something blue something borrowed  something blue dareka so these folks at  the start of their love journey love it